hi
i'm james ward a developer advocate at
google cloud
and this session is on comparing docker
methods
so we're going to go over docker files
build packs
and some great things with grawl vm and
jib so we're actually going to do this
all as live demos
so here we go let's start out exploring
containers
by just using them and then we'll take a
look inside
let's just run a container locally so
i'm going to say docker run
and then i'm going to tell it to map a
port so i'm going to use port 8080
until to map the port in the container
8080 to
my localhost 8080 and then we'll give it
the container to run
and this is going to be either a docker
hub
container or a url to a container i'm
going to give it the url to gcr.io
slash hello so that is a url that it'll
pull the container down from so let's
run this and see what happens
now i already had the container on my
local machine so it didn't have to
download anything
but you can see it's actually started up
the container now so it uses
virtualization
on my machine to take the contents of
the container
and run them and that's how we get
containers to have
a consistent running across different
platforms
and operating systems and all that let's
go take a quick look at this application
in my browser so i can just go to
localhost 8080
and there we go we've got now our
application up and running
okay so we're able to run that container
locally
and that's great but one of the great
things about containers is that they're
easily portable
so that we can run them other places too
we can run them in kubernetes we can run
them on a service called cloud run
or anywhere else that can run containers
so i'm going to go
into cloud run on google cloud
and we're going to go create a new
service
and we'll say we want to run it in the
iowa
region we need to give it a name so
we'll just call this one
hello containers i'm going to allow
unauthentic
unauthenticated invocations and then i
need to give it
a container image url so i'm going to
again give it that
gcr dot io cloud run hello
and then i can just hit create so that
will now pull that container down
and start it up on underlying
infrastructure
for my service on cloud run looks like
that's all done and ready to go so now i
can just
open up this url and there we go now we
see that container running there in the
browser
cloud run is serverless for containers
so it
takes containers as the deployment unit
and then
it will start up as many instances as
demand
dictates to run that application and of
course we can see logs and
details and metrics and all the other
great stuff here for this service
running on cloud run
and we could do the same thing on
kubernetes we can run this
the same container on kubernetes or
anywhere that docker will run
okay now we've seen that container
running both locally and on cloud run
but let's actually go look and see what
that container is
to do this i'm going to use a tool
called dive and so i'm going to say
let's do dive on that container
and so now we're getting a bunch of
information
about this container and what's in it
there are layers in a container
and these layers have different
files on a file system so you can think
of a container
as kind of like a zip file with some
metadata about
what other layers it depends on and so
we can build up
a stack of layers to have everything
that we need in our container so that it
can run
so we can see different layers here you
can see those up in the top left
and we can see the first layer was only
5.6 megabytes so nice and small for that
one
and then we can go and browse the files
that are in there so you can see this
looks like
a basic operating system here maybe
ubuntu or debian based operating system
or busybox looks like
so that was the first layer and pretty
small
then we can see some other layers that
are added on top of that
we add some ca certificates then there's
another layer which looks like it's
adding some
um some server pieces to it
and we and then there's an index.html
that gets added in a layer
and then some svgs some assets so
that the whole image size the whole
container image size is only
17 megabytes for this particular one so
that's nice and small
everything that's needed to have a
portable container that can run
anywhere that runs containers okay
so that's our basic intro to containers
but now let's talk about how we create
containers to explore creating
containers
let's go look at an application that we
want to take from source code to a
container
so what we're going to do is go over to
github
i have a repo under my github james
warden comparing docker methods
and there's some different branches that
we're going to be walking through the
first branch we're going to walk through
is the dockerfile method and we'll open
this up in intellij so that we can
explore it a little better
i'm going to be using a java maven
project
for our explorations here but of course
uh really anything can be turned into a
container these days so
all of the stuff should apply no matter
what technical technology you're using
if you're using node or go or python
whatever it should be able to be easily
turned into a container
and we'll have a lot of similar methods
for doing so
okay so for our first method of turning
something into
into a container we're going to use a
docker file and this is
kind of the traditional standard for how
you take something and turn it into a
container
let me first walk you through this
project so you can get an idea for the
layout
so this is a maven project so we have
our palm file which defines how
our project is going to be built and
then we have our source code
which in this case i'm just using a
plain
java class that's starting up a server
and when there's a request it's going to
respond with hello world
so super simple application so let's
take a look at how this works for the
dockerfile method
i have a docker file and the first part
of the docker file
is talking about how this thing is going
to be built
from source code into something that can
run so what i do
is i start from another container and i
give it a
indicator as builder which is going to
say this is
this is just the builder part of the
package and won't go into my final
container i set the work directory to
slash app
i copy the contents of my source into
the container
then i run maven compile and then
jar clone jar and that will create the
jar file so that i can run my
application in this case
so i've got that now in the as builder
part
but i need to now take that and put it
into my final container so i do another
from
and this time i give it the base image
that i'm going to use
for this for my my production
container image and so i'm using the
open jdk
jre and then i'm copying from the
builder
that jar file that was created from
maven compile in jar jar
and then putting that on server.jar
and then i tell it a command to use to
when the container starts so i say java
minus jar
that server chart okay so that's a
pretty straightforward way to go from
source code to the
container and we can go try this out
so to try i'm going to say docker build
and then i'm going to give it a tag
the tag is the either the url
or the local coordinates to this thing
and in this case i'm not going to use a
remote registry which we'll talk about
later
so i'm just going to say that my tag is
going to be
let's copy this and paste it and then
i'm going to
say colon where i get a chance to
specify like a version or something like
that
and in my case i'm going to say this is
docker file and then i need to tell
docker
what to actually build and so i'm going
to say dot and so it's going to find the
docker file there
and now what docker will do is it'll go
download if it needs to
the different layers the docker
container layers so that it can build
this
you'll see it's downloading those from
in this case docker hub
is where it's getting that adopt open
jdk open jdk 11 from
and now it's walking through all the
steps in the docker file running the
maven build so now
because this is running outside of my
local file system it doesn't have access
to
the maven local cache so it's
downloading all the maven stuff that it
needs
and uh and it it has the jdk already but
it alright and it needed to download
maven
and then maven's dependencies so it's
downloading all that from maven central
and then it's going to do the compile
should be able to start that up
in a second and then once
it gets compiled it'll create the jar
file and then
from that jar file it'll create that
finer final container image
okay so it's created the jar file and
you'll see it says it's removing those
intermediate containers because it
didn't need those any longer for the
final
image and then it's assembling the final
image
starting with the open jdk 11 jre as the
base image
and then copying that server jar file in
and then setting up that command
okay so now we can uh we can actually
run this thing
so what i can do is say let's docker
run i do need to map the port
like i did before let's map it to your
8080
and then i'm going to tell it that
container image to run
so let's run that thing and see how it
works locally
let's go to our localhost 8080
and great our hello world works okay so
we've got this working locally
and and we've got the container image
but now let's go use that dive tool
and take a look at what's actually in
this container and how it's structured
so diving in we'll see that dive opens
it up we can see the layers we see
a base uh image that is our operating
system
and then it's got a few other pieces
here that are tweaking some things in
the operating system
it looks like it's installing some
ca certificates and font config into the
container
and then this 129 mig layer is probably
our jre
and then we've got the final layer which
is copying in our server jar
file and adding that into the container
and that one in our case is pretty small
so total here of 229 megs for all the
layers of our application
now it's nice that we have this layering
of our of
docker containers because that makes the
cache and validation really great
because if i create a new version of
this container that only changes that
final layer
with a new jar file then it doesn't have
to recreate and in a lot of cases
doesn't have to pull down
those those layers that it already has
so
uh there's these shaw uh shot digests
that that make it so that caching works
really well for each layer
that our container is assembled from
okay so really great question caching
support
with the layers in docker okay so that
was the first method for
creating a docker container with a
docker file
all right now for the second method of
building containers
we're going to use something called jib
so i'm going to go
and switch my branch and this repo over
to the jib branch and we'll check that
out
and now let's go pull up the palm file
and we'll learn a little bit about jib
so jib is a jvm
based library that can plug into maven
and gradle
and creates container images so all we
have to do in the case of maven is add
that plugin
and now we can use jib so to build our
container
so the source code didn't change nothing
else changed you'll see that i don't
have a docker file anymore because
we don't need one because we're going to
use jib and we could do this from maven
or gradle
and i think there's other other jvm
based build plugins as well
okay so to do this we're going to call
maven with a target of jib docker build
so let's go do that here run that so
we're going to first run the compile
then jib docker build and we're going to
tell it the image name that we want to
store
which is comparing docker methods colon
jib
okay now jib is assembling our container
and it did that super
fast because jib doesn't actually use
the typical docker method to create
these containers
it has its own implementation and it's
super fast and has great caching support
as well so
let's go do our dive on this container
now
and take a look at what's in inside of
this container
so dive in and we'll see that
our total container size is a little bit
less this time 197 megs i think because
we're probably using a different
base image so we've got our base image
with our operating system
different pieces of the operating system
and then the jvm that we're using
is probably that layer there and then
the jib plugin kicks in
and adds some pieces in and it looks
like there's a layer here that's used
for our dependencies which we'll get
into in a minute
and then the final layer which is our
class file for our code of this project
so uh jib did a great job creating
this uh this nice little container for
us
now let's let's run this thing and make
sure that everything works
i can just go say let's run the jib
one of those and let's go refresh make
sure that our container works
yeah it does okay so that's our
container created with jib
one of the nice things that jib does
though is you may have seen it there
it adds a layer for the dependencies in
our application
so in this case my application doesn't
have any dependencies
it's just a basic java application but
let's switch over to the
jib spring boot branch and then
we'll have some dependencies so in the
case of spring boot
i have some dependencies in this case
just the spring boot starter webflux
so that is my dependency with a whole
bunch of other dependencies
underneath it that i'm going to use uh
in here and so if we go back and run
that
maven docker build again
and we'll give this a different name
we'll call it spring jib dash spring
boot
then it's going to take the dependencies
and copy those dependencies into a layer
as well
and you'll remember that the caching in
docker
makes it so that the caching validation
is really nice
so let's use dive and go check this
thing out
okay so looking at this we'll see that
now there's this layer
added by jib which is 18 megs and you'll
see over on the right that this is all
the dependencies that come
in from my dependency on spring boot so
18 megs of dependencies that got pulled
in for that spring boot web flex
dependency and then all the way down to
my
particular code that was added on
another layer so if we don't change our
dependencies then that layer doesn't
change which is super nice
only when we change the dependencies
with that layer change
and only when we change our application
code would this uh top layer
change so total now 216 megs with
those dependencies uh with most of that
being the jvm okay so
that's the uh jib method and that works
on
any jvm based build but let's take a
look at
yet another method so i'm gonna go
switch over to
the build packs branch let's check out
this one
so build packs are an incubating cncf
standard
and it's a way to be able to really
throw almost any source code
at a tool uh the build packs tool
and have it the build packs know how to
turn that source code
into a container image so there's no
plugin
in my palm for doing this nothing
special in there
uh this um there's nothing in my project
no doctor file
and what we're going to do is run a tool
called pac that will turn
this my code into a container image
i'm going to be using the google cloud
google cloud build packs so there's
different build packs that you can use
and if we go to github and go to
the build packs repo on google cloud
platform
what we'll see is information about the
google cloud build packs the ones that
we'll be using
and the different languages that are
supported go nodepythonjava.net
okay so that means that we can give it
any application built with those
technologies
and it should be able to turn that into
a container image without
our our code or our build plug-in having
to have any knowledge
of how to go to be turned into a
container image
so let's give this a try i've already
installed this tool called pack
you can just download it from the build
pack website
but then you give it the builder image
to use which is also a docker
container and so this is the build pack
so the java build pack the go build pack
from google cloud build packs and then
we give it the
the tag that we're going to use so let's
run pack build on this thing
and turn that source code into a
container image and then we'll take a
look
at the container in dive
there's also nice caching in build packs
they do a good job
of preserving stuff across builds
and you'll see that it did this
restoring phase so first it actually did
a detecting phase
and it detected that hey this is a java
application
and it knows how to build java
applications so then it restored from
cache our m2 cache so it didn't have to
redownload stuff
it did the maven clean package and then
it exported the layers
okay so now we've got um our
uh let's see that was build pack let's
go now
dive into that one so let's run this on
the build pack
one and let's try build packs i think
that's what it was plural
okay so now this is pulling that into
dive and now we can see the layers that
were created from build packs
for this application we can see a base
image which looks like the operating
system and then some other things on top
of that
and then we get down into this large
layer which is
probably the jvm layer and then we have
i think a layer for dependencies and a
layer for our application something
along those lines
so similarly layering to what we saw
with the jvm
but you'll see that um in this case the
the base images that it chose were
larger than the ones that were chosen by
jib
you can customize that if you want but
the total image size for this one is 436
megabytes
but really nice that we didn't have to
have anything in our project that telled
it
how to create a container image from our
source code
okay and just for the sake of
validation let's go run our docker
run give it the port 8080 to
8080 and run this thing and make sure
that
our application built with build packs
works hello world
great it still works okay
so that was the method of using build
packs to go from
our source code to our docker container
image
now let's check out another option which
is
going to use the dockerfile option we
saw before but in the case of jvm
projects can result in really small
binaries so for this one
i'm going to switch over to a branch
called grawl vm
and for girl vm the graph vm one uh
what we're doing is we're using the
docker file because
we're doing some stuff that we can't do
with jib
or with build packs what we're going to
do is we're going to use this thing
called grawl vm to ahead of time compile
our jvm-based application into a native
executable so i'm giving it the graviem
base image there for a builder and then
i'm installing
into here native image which is a tool
for graw vm to create those native
images
and then i'm also downloading a library
a native binding library that we can use
so that
our application doesn't have any runtime
dependencies on
anything and not even an operating
system
and then i'm going to do my maven
compile create my jar
and now i'm going to run the native
image tool and i'm going to tell it
some parameters here for when it creates
the native image i'm telling you to use
that
mucil c bundle that i downloaded earlier
and a few other things static is what
does
the static binding of the to the native
libraries okay now here's the cool part
is that
for my final image i'm saying from
scratch which gives me
a plain nothing in it docker image
and now i'm copying the output of native
image
which is this binary executable called
web app
copying that into the container and then
telling it to run that
web app okay so this is a jvm based
application that we're turning into a
native application with no
bindings to or built-in bindings to
the native native code that's needed
so let's go run this one which i'm going
to just copy this docker command here
because we're using a docker file we're
going to
do the docker build and give it that
that tag there
okay so now it's uh it's doing the
the builder stage of the docker build it
has
downloaded those those native image
components and the
mucil c components and now it's doing
the
uh maven build so again it's gonna have
to go download
the maven stuff from maven central so
that maven can run
and so that'll take a minute to download
everything that it needs and then it
will create our jar file
or compile the code create the jar file
and then
it will run native image
on that jar file to to
be able to turn it into that native
executable
so all this takes a little bit of time
and
just a recommendation no matter what
method you're using
i only create my container images
usually as part of my cicd
process when i'm developing locally for
jvm applications
i'm just using the the standard java run
tooling with a jvm installed locally so
i get a really quick
feedback cycle and i'm not not creating
container images
as part of my local development i just
have my ci
cd server create those those images
uh because those are the artifacts that
are needed to run in kubernetes or cloud
run
or wherever you want to run your
container images
okay so native image is now running on
our jar files and
has has ahead of time compiled that jvm
application
into a native binary and then it has
stored that into the docker container
and now we can run this
container and let's make sure it works
so let's say
run and then let's map our port
okay run that thing so one of the things
that's really nice
about grav vm native images is that they
start up really fast and usually use a
lot less memory
so they work great in serverless
environments that are benefit from that
okay looks like everything's working
that's awesome now let's use our dive
tool
and let's go explore our native image
that was created here
so now you'll see because i did that
from scratch
i only have one layer in my docker
container
and that one layer only contains that
one file web app
and it's 11 minutes so i was able to
have no operating system in this
container
and because all the native bindings are
built into the executable that it needs
and so super small but this is still a
jvm
application just through grav vm native
image was able to
ahead of time compile the whole thing
down into a native executable
so super cool uh and one thing that you
can do
with uh containers and uh with with jvm
based applications
okay so that was exploring different
ways of creating
docker containers and the some of the
impacts that you have with doing so
now let's learn a little bit about
docker registries docker registries are
places that we can store these
containers
so that they can be easily accessed from
different machines
so there's a number of docker registries
out there one of them the most typical
one that people
use is just docker hub so
docker hub is hub.docker.com and you can
sign up for an account and store your
containers up on docker hub and a lot of
the containers that we're using as space
images that's where they come from
now for your projects on google cloud
there's two other places where you can
store
your docker containers so let's go over
into the cloud console
and check those out so there's the
container registry is the traditional
place to
store containers so you can see i've got
a bunch of containers stored up on
the google container registry and you'll
you'll remember
from when we did like the build pack
sample that the build packs are stored
up there as well
the cloud run hello world is stored up
there on the google container registry
there's another place on google cloud
which is newer
and this is called the artifact registry
the artifact registry is cool because it
supports not just docker containers
but you can also store maven artifacts
npm artifacts
that kind of stuff up there as well so
not just docker containers
so you can check that out currently in
beta
okay so let's go back to the container
registry
and let's go store create a container
that will store
up on the google container registry so
i'm going to switch
over to the um let's go
to the jib branch here and use that one
okay uh let's go now back to our command
where we're gonna create our container
image all right so let's copy
that command that we used before and
paste it in here
and then instead of saying jib docker
build i'm going to say
jib build and then i'm going to give it
the coordinates to the google container
registry so i'm going to say gcr.io
and then my project id on google cloud
so it's jw demo
and then my artifact name okay let's try
to run this
and what it should do is create that
container image and store it up on the
google container registry
so looks like it's pushing those layers
up to the google container registry
and in this case it didn't need the
local docker daemon
because it didn't actually store that on
the local docker daemon
okay now if we refresh the google
container registry
and we come down we should see a new
docker container image here comparing
docker methods
and then we see that one that i just
pushed there and then i can come
and click on this and say let's deploy
it on cloud run gke
gce whatever so that's uh
how easy it is to be able to take
source code and get that container image
up on the google container registry
let's go and and walk through one other
quick step for this
which is deploying this on cloud run
which you've seen already but i want to
show you what it looks like
if we were to do it from that menu so
just like we saw before we can create a
service we can give it the service name
we can tell it yes an authentic
unauthenticated request the container
image url
and then let's hit create okay so now
it's creating that service
from that source code and deploying the
new revision
and that will be up and running in
just a second okay
great so it's up and running and there
it is hello world
running up on the cloud so there's
if you do want to play around with this
stuff there's a really easy way to do
that
which is if you go to my comparing
docker methods repo
and then you can pick any of these
different uh
different methods via different branches
let's just go back to that like jib one
then there's a button that you can click
on here which so let's click this run on
google cloud button
and when we do where it's going to take
us into something called cloud shell
which will automate those steps that
i've walked through on the command line
and so this just provides a nice easy
way for you to learn
about using these different methods for
building docker containers and deploying
them
up on cloud run so it's cloned that git
repo
and checked out the branch that we were
on and then it's asking me which project
i want to use i'm saying jw demo
where do i want to deploy us central one
is the region
and now what it'll do is run that maven
jib task on this repo
so that's now running and creating our
container image
using jib storing that container image
up on the google container registry so
there you go you see that it's doing
that maven package you
build giving it the image parameter so
just like we did from the command line
but this is doing it all for you so you
don't have to remember all the steps
just click that button and you can do it
on any of those
branches within that repo and that'll
help you
get started so now it's doing the
g-cloud run deployed deploying that
container image
up on the cloud and then we should see
this thing deployed and up and running
here
in just a second so that's a super
easy way to get started and that is on
my github
so github james ward and then that's
under the comparing docker methods
uh repo there so you and then you can
select the branch that you want to go
see
okay so our app was deployed up on cloud
run we can open it up
and see once again our lovely hello
world
okay so that is uh that is the comparing
docker methods with files jib and
build packs and then also some graw vm
thrown in there for
native images with the jvm
all right that was comparing docker
methods
and i hope that was useful for you i
really appreciate you watching hope you
got a lot of it
thanks